[Musique]
le fait de mettre des voitures sur les
routes de mettre véhicules autonomes sur
les routes sans les avoir complètement
tester en situation presque réel mais en
dehors des routes est problématique
d'abord parce qu'ils aient des risques
d'accident et aussi parce que c'est une
imposition aux citoyens citoyennes d'une
situation qu'ils peuvent ne pas vouloir
rencontrer à fait présentement les
véhicules sont assez sur la voie
publique sont testés dans des contextes
rêvant de test et de déploiement
on comprend pas ça dans le véhicule pour
le laisser sur la route on encadre
l'utilisation de ces véhicules et déjà
qu'ils se plaisent à dire que l'arrivée
de véhicules autonomes à enrayer toutes
les collisions sur la route
je pense qu'il faut pas exagérer non
plus je pense que chaque vie sauvée et
une vies sauvées si on ne peut pas le
mettre de côté
[Musique]